[Musique]
au Grand Mont les grandes installations
pour recevoir les négociateurs du monde
entier qui participent à la 15e
Conférence des Parties à la Convention
sur la diversité biologique des Nations
Unies la COP 15
une rencontre en haut lieu pour discuter
d'un sujet sérieux rien de moins que de
l'effondrement de la biodiversité on va
aimer l'Yonne
sur les 8 millions d'espèces vivantes
connues un million sont menacés
d'extinction d'ici la fin du siècle
rappelle la secrétaire général de la
Convention sur la diversité biologique
et selon les scientifiques la crise du
vivant à l'échelle planétaire a atteint
son paroxysme
50% des coraux sont disparus 66% de
l'environnement marin et dégradé tout
comme 75% des terres
notre vie dépend de la biodiversité
c'est la nourriture que nous mangeons
l’air que nous respirons loup que nous
buvons elle permet de réguler le climat
et de produire des médicaments
précise-t-elle une crise qui concerne
tous ces chacun même le secteur privé
alors que les économistes estiment que
la moitié du PIB mondial dépend de la
nature c'est probablement la Coop la
plus importante de l'histoire des
copains biodiversité comme plusieurs
l'hémisphère ou changement climatique du
Québec voit dans cette COP15 l'occasion
à saisir pour freiner la débâcle et
élaborer un cadre mondial pour la
prochaine décennie voici d'abord de
d'avoir des règles de protection de la
nature donc essayez de protéger 30% de
la planète et des Océans ça c'est un
grand défi on va également parler
d'agriculture comment est-ce qu'on va
pratiquer notre agriculture les acteurs
de la société civile eux profiteront de
l'occasion pour faire pression sur les
gouvernements
annonce l'agrandissement du parc marin
du Saguenay Saint-Laurent pour la
protection du béluga c'est un modèle qui
fonctionne bien c'est un beau modèle de
collaboration un beau modèle de
gouvernance pour une heure protégée et
il rappelle que la biodiversité joue un
rôle de premier plan pour contrer la
crise climatique on estime à de 30 à 40%
la part des solutions naturelles pour
lutter contre le climat d'ici 2030 puis
le meilleur séquestreur de carbone c'est
c'est les arbres là qu'on a autour de
nous on espère
que la guerre reste l'argent et avec le
bilan mitigé de la COP 27 en Égypte
plusieurs pensent que la partie est loin
d'être gagnée ici Elisa serre a du
Canada Montréal